y ambos tomaron la lucha contra la
corrupción como bandera de campaña
él asegura sin titubear que ganará en
primera vuelta
rodolf hernández es un candidato atípico
no es conocido por gran parte de los
colombianos no ha realizado eventos
públicos pero en las encuestas tempranas
tiene alrededor de un 13% en intención
de voto sólo por debajo de gustavo petro
éstos gracias a su presencia en redes
sociales una estrategia que engancha y
ha consolidado su imagen entre sus más
de 260 mil seguidores fue alcalde de la
ciudad de bucaramanga entre 2016 y 2019
cuando renunció tras ser suspendido en
dos ocasiones y ahora aspira a la casa
de nariño manos libres
independiente hasta el final
desmiento absolutamente que mi campaña
esté por unirse a ningún nombre
coalición o partido político
no está exento de polémica se
caracteriza por comentarios y reacciones
explosivas que incluso le han costado
juicios disciplinarios y que se ha
tildado de misógino y xenófobo
en 2018 agredió a un concejal siendo
alcalde en 2019 aseguró que las mujeres
venezolanas eran fábricas de niños
pobres por hechos ocurridos durante su
alcaldía en los que estaría envuelto su
hijo luis carlos enfrenta una
investigación penal y otra disciplinaria
es ingeniero y ha obtenido su patrimonio
de 100 millones de dólares según el
mismo lo dice de la construcción lo que
le permitió entrar a la política sin el
apoyo de los clanes tradicionales y el
cero por otra parte está ella para
muchos un símbolo de la reconciliación
en colombia para otros una política
ajena y desconectada de la realidad del
país es una recuperación fundamental
ingrid betancourt fue integrante del
congreso entre el 94 y 2002 se destacó
por su lucha contra la corrupción y la
búsqueda de una salida pacífica al
conflicto armado porque obviamente en su
mayoría el congreso sigue en manos de
una maquinaria y de unos caciques
corruptos en 2002 siendo candidata
presidencial fue secuestrada por la
guerrilla de las farc pasó seis años en
cautiverio tras su liberación se retiró
de la esfera política y vio gran parte
de este tiempo en francia y reino unido-
hasta enero de 2022 hizo parte de la
alianza centro esperanza pero la no
argumentando que hay candidatos que
reciben apoyos de personas vinculadas
con casos de corrupción esta falta de
posición clara nos obliga a asumir el
liderazgo de una batalla que tenemos que
dar y ganar en colombia' por una
política limpia justa y que no le robe
las oportunidades a los 51 millones de
colombianos su principal reto será
impactar a los colombianos cuando falta
poco para los comicios